as I said we're very pleased to have my
colleague and friend co-op about with us
Paul as many of you know is the dollar
professor of they all nodded Audrey
presence and piety medicine in law at
Columbia University he's also one of the
I think world's leading experts in
bioethics and particularly bioethics and
psychiatry and there's why number of
mental health issues that raise ethical
and legal questions that many of us deal
with he is the head of the center of
excellence in ethical legal social
implications of research on psychiatric
neurological and behavioral conditions
conditions as it otherwise known as
brain genetics and he has many of you
also know coin the term therapeutic
misconception which has been an
extremely useful and important concept
for all of us who involved in research
in any way he's written many many
articles books has been media numerous
occasions and we are delighted that an
honor to have you with us today so
please join me in welcoming here so
thank you Bob I feel certain asymmetry
since you're all over there and all over
here but I need to control the slide so
so be it if you're interested in moving
over this way that would be that would
be fine so Bob thank you for inviting me
to join you all here this evening I
always get a kick out of coming back
into Hamilton Hall I was an
undergraduate here at Columbia just a
couple of years ago and spent a lot of
time in this building and it's fun every
time I walk I walk back in what I'm
going to be talking about today as you
know our research ethics and where they
came from as it were and where they're
likely to be going in the foreseeable
future
I would invite you as I'm going through
this to stop me as I go along if there
are questions you have or comments that
you want to make there will be time at
the end for additional questions but I'd
rather deal with things as we go along
if I'm going to get to it later on I'll
tell you that I'll get to it later on
but otherwise we'll just deal with them
as as you have them and minimize the
risk of your not remembering at the end
so essentially there are two sets of
issues we're going to address what is
the history of regulation of research
and the implementation of ethical
approaches to human subjects of research
in particular informed consent because
so much of ethical regulation focuses on
informed consent and because it's a
particular interest of mine but we'll
talk about research regulation more
broadly and then we'll talk a little bit
about where research ethics are heading
just focused on a few selected issues
and then we'll have time for discussion
so the ethics of research do not proceed
the beginning of medical research itself
which is in the history of the world a
relatively recent phenomenon the first
clinical trial if you will occurred in
1747 just seven years before this
university was founded and it took place
in England it was Lynn's study of scurvy
among British sailors and it was done in
a fairly classical controlled fashion
that is Lind equipped some ships in the
British Navy where scurvy was a major
issue as the Navy was sailing around the
world with limes that the
sailors who later acquired the nickname
of limeys could get juice from during
the course of the voyage and other ships
did not have such possibility such
opportunities and he studied the
differential rate of scurvy in those two
under those two conditions and
established that there was something in
citrus that prevented the development of
scurvy interestingly it took about
another 50 years before the British Navy
universalized the requirement that
citrus fruits and citrus juice be
carried on it's on its ships and it was
another 50 years before scurvy was
eliminated from the British Navy another
early example of research comes from
Pierre louys studies in Paris in the
1820s published in the 1830s of
bloodletting as a treatment for in
particular pneumonia there was a belief
in the early 19th century an old belief
that pneumonia represented a congestion
of the lungs not far off from reality
but that the way to treat it would be to
remove blood from the body several vein
and take out a pint or two of blood in
order to reduce the blood volume and
therefore reduce the congestion Louie
was a little bit skeptical about this
received wisdom and decided to
essentially randomize his patients into
those who came in with pneumonia and had
bloodletting and those who didn't by the
end of his study eat established fairly
conclusively that bloodletting was more
likely to lead to death in patients with
pneumonia than not
taking blood from them and that changed
the treatment of pneumonia we still
didn't have effective treatments for
another century beyond that when the
antibiotics in the 1930s streptomycin
our first introduced and later in the
19th century we see the pace of clinical
trials accelerate lots of studies of
nutritional diseases I can tell you the
story of beriberi in the japanese navy
very similar story to what went on in
the British Navy with scurvy and
infectious diseases as well however in
none of these studies as far as we know
was consent obtained from the research
subjects indeed in Lynn's study and
Pierre louys bloodletting studies it
seems fairly clear that the subjects of
the research had no idea that they were
subjects of research they went into the
doctor or Louise case and he did what he
was going to do either he took blood
from them or he didn't they didn't have
the choice and they were unaware that he
was testing a medical hypothesis there
were some leading physicians by the late
19th century william osler the father of
modern of medicine one of them who are
on record as urging that consent be
obtained from human subjects although
they weren't then conceptualized as
human subjects but it is pretty clear
that that that was rarely done the first
governmental regulations come not in the
United States but in Prussia in the
1890s this is after German unifications
though this is a
Shin state statute not a German national
statute which was implemented after
patients in oppression hospitals as part
of some experiment of some sort were
inoculated with syphilis deliberately
and without their knowledge and syphilis
of course the 1890s had no treatment
when that became public there was an
uproar uproar and Prussia introduced
regulations requiring patient consent
before they could be entered into
clinical studies the first known consent
form that is extant comes from Colonel
Walter Reed's studies of yellow fever in
Cuba during and after the
spanish-american war Reed used a
combination of American soldiers and
Cuban civilians as his research subjects
exposed some of them to the bedding of
people who had had yellow fever since
there was a hypothesis that that was how
yellow fever was transmitted that was
how smallpox was transmitted why not
yellow fever and some of them to the
bite of the anopheles mosquito which it
turned out in fact was the vector that
transmitted yellow fever the consent
form which you can track down online was
a one page long a model of concession
and pretty much told the subjects
everything they needed to know about
what would happen to them and about the
incentives for participation they were
offered one hundred dollars in gold for
participating in the in the mosquito
bite part of the study and if they
contracted and died from yellow fever
their families would get to
dollars in gold and in many respects as
primitive as Walter Reed's approach
seems today it really was way ahead of
its time in terms of respect for the
subjects who were entering his study and
a clear communication of what a study
was about what the procedures were that
were involved and what the risks of
participation were it was clear to
everybody that they could die they won't
me do that sort of revolutionaries yeah
so you know there's the records are not
complete it is clear as I understand it
at the War Department in Washington was
very concerned about American public
reaction to the youths not of Cuban
civilians but of American soldiers in
these studies and if it was to be the
case that they were to be involved than
it had to be on a strictly voluntary
basis with some sort of compensation and
with a clear understanding of what they
were letting themselves in for it's not
clear that the War Department required a
consent form per se but with those
restrictions it's undoubtedly seemed
logical to read to embody that in a
written document and have them sign it
which they did which they did yeah
tation hear that the nations are she
understood
said
yeah it's not clear today that people
who enter into research studies actually
understand what they're signing so we
have no idea what they understood back
then although the form I'm if you read
it today's it is quite clear there's not
a lot of jargon you could die if you die
your family gets two hundred dollars you
know it was it was written without the
legal and medical gobbledygook that is
so prevalent in our consent forms today
the Cuban Spanish speaking Cuban
civilians that you know all bets are off
I have no idea really what they were
able to to understand ironically the
next notable step in the evolution of
regulation of research comes in Germany
in 1931 about a year and a half before
the Nazi take over Germany passes a law
this is why Mr Germany passes a statute
requiring that patient subjects received
explanations of experimental or
innovative treatments and in the in the
regulatory mind experimental and
innovative were often linked even though
today we would consider them to be quite
different an innovation is not
necessarily part of an experiment it
could be you know a surgeon who decides
he's got a better way to tie a knot or a
better approach a better incision to use
for a particular operation which
surgeons continue to do to this day
experimental treatments imply some sort
of systematic effort to assess whether
something is effective as an example of
just how early though consent to
research and the importance of consent
to research reach the popular mind I
want to offer you an example from George
Bernard Shaw's Pygmalion which was
written in the first decade
of the 20th century and later becomes
the play and the movie my fair lady I'm
going to share some dialogue with you
that is almost the same almost identical
in Pygmalion and in my fair lady much of
my fair lady much of the dialogue is
taken verbatim from Shaw's dialogue and
for those of you who know the play liza
doolittle the flower girl at Covent
Garden has been approached by Henry
Higgins who is a linguist professor of
linguistics and she agrees or she comes
to his house seeking his help for
turning her into a lady somebody who can
speak the way a lady would speak and he
tells her that he's willing to do it but
Higgins has a friend Colonel Pickering
who's quite worried about Eliza really
understanding what it is she's getting
into so he pipes up and says excuse me
Higgins I really must interfere if this
girl is to put herself in your hands for
six months for an experiment in teaching
she must understand thoroughly what
she's doing Higgins how can she she's
incapable of understanding anything
besides do any of us understand what
we're doing if we did would we ever do
it I can't tell you how many
investigators today I hear some variant
of that response from Pickering very
clever iggins but not sound sense
Higgins no use explaining as a military
man Pickering you ought to know that
give her her orders that's what she
wants however Eliza your to live here
for the next six months learning how to
speak beautifully like a lady in a
florist shop if you're good and do
whatever you're told you shall sleep in
a proper bedroom and have lots to eat
and money to buy chocolates and
rides and taxis this is a little data
this is when it was a pleasure to take a
ride if you're naughty an idol you will
sleep in the back kitchen among the
black beetles and be wallop by mrs.
Pierce with a broomstick at the end of
six months you shall go to Buckingham
Palace in a carriage beautifully dressed
if the King finds out you're not a lady
you will be taken by the police to the
Tower of London where you're ahead will
be cut off as a warning to other
presumptuous flower girls if you're not
found out you shall have a presence of
seven and sixpence to start life with is
a lady in a shop if you refuse this
offer you will be a most ungrateful and
wicked girl and the angels will weep for
you now are you satisfied Pickering so
interestingly this this dialogue here
contains all three of the essential
elements of informed consent as we
conceptualize it today Pickering's
concern is that lies Oh be told what's
going to happen to her Higgins response
focuses on her competence or capacity to
understand or more appreciate that
information and Liza has her own bottom
line here you're a big bully you are I
won't stay here if I don't like I won't
let nobody well up me so voluntariness
is really what she's focusing on I'll do
it if i want to but when I'm done I'm
out of here and there's no way you can
keep me by the way Higgins is right
neither lies own or as it turns out
Henry Higgins himself can truly
appreciate what the consequences of this
little experiment are going to be but
despite the popular view embodied in
Shaw's a play it's clear that in the
period leading up to World War two
research studies were frequently
in fact probably almost always conducted
without the knowledge or consent of the
participants particularly in clinical
settings what changes everything is what
goes on in the Nazi death camps in world
war two and that comes out to world
attention in the Nuremberg doctors
trials after the war the doctors were
the first of the Nazis to be tried even
before the Nazi leaders surviving
leaders are put on trial the doctors
trial takes place beginning in 1946 in
fact if you read accounts of the trials
themselves Nuremberg wasn't even fully
pacified at that point there were
saboteurs and snipers unreconstructed
Nazis still roaming around the city and
blowing things up but the doctors were
on trial for atrocities that they
committed in the death camps in studies
of unwilling subjects who were clearly
being used without their consent and the
studies were pretty horrendous to give
you a couple of examples there were the
gangrene studies where an incision was
made in a limb of an individual which
was then rubbed with dirt and glass
beads the glass beads were there to make
sure that the wound couldn't heal
effectively and the natural history of
the development of gangrene was then
observed until the person died not that
we didn't know what the natural history
of gangrene was but there you go there
were also the experiments in attempting
to reattach severed limbs in which first
of course limbs had to be severed turns
out Nazi doctors didn't know how to
reattach severed limbs and most of those
people died as well they're horrendous
pictures of dumpsters full of limbs
severed I could go on but you get the
idea the tribunal the international
panel of ja
were pretty horrified by what they heard
and as part of their decision in the
doctors trial produced a 10-point
document which is to this day known as
the Nuremberg code the first principle
of which is the voluntary consent of
human subject of the human subject is
absolutely essential it turns out of
course today the voluntary consent of
the human subject is not absolutely
essential we can talk about that as well
but in reaction to what they heard going
on in the death camps this seemed to
them like an unassailable follow Chris
me that early in the 20th century we
started to see a movement for the right
to
refuse treatment and the right to
consent to treatment with Shawn dorvan
another early right to refuse case
Ernie's right to know how come the that
movement didn't make it into the
research that's a great question in fact
you're a little early not for Sloan Dorf
because that's in the 20s but she loaned
our fee is a is an anomalous case that
really begins to have impact only after
the later informed consent cases come
along and they're looking for some sort
of president so long Dourif had all its
no impact when it was actually decided
so let's hold that because you'll see
where they do come in that that does
come in but not quite yet happens in the
1950s and the nuremberg tribunal at its
view as to what should be disclosed to
research subjects before the acceptance
of an affirmative decision by the
subject there should be made known to
him the nature duration and purpose of
the experiment the method and means by
which it's to be conducted all
inconveniences and hazards reasonably to
be expected and the effects upon his
health or person which may possibly come
from his participation in the experiment
and that's not a bad statement of what
even today as you'll see we focus on in
obtaining consent from research subjects
yes oh that's a complicated question of
international law Nuremberg made things
up as it went along because there was no
pre-existing body of international law
and so the victors in World War two
created a tribunal and some basic
procedures that were to be followed it
gave rise subsequently to a body of
international law which has developed a
good deal since that time but this is
where the notion of crimes against
humanity come
from as a basis for supranational action
and the International Criminal Court in
The Hague today which you know is is
looking at murders in Kenya and and
massacres and genocide in Rwanda and
killings in Bosnia draws its inspiration
and original model from the Nuremberg
Tribunal a more complex question which I
don't know that we have time to explore
in depth is where did the standard that
the Nuremberg Tribunal applies come from
because it clearly was not what was
going on even in any of the Allied
countries as a general rule and the
answer is that the tribunal went to the
American Medical Association and had two
American experts and visine them what if
whom Andrew IV goes back to the AMA and
asked them to approve a set of
principles which are later embodied in
the code which they do and which sound
good but which clearly don't reflect the
standard of care in American research
settings to that point in time so when
the Nazi doctors complained that they
were being judged unfairly because the
standard applied to them was applied to
nobody else there was a grain of truth
in their in their complaint on the other
hand nobody else was chopping off limbs
and trying to reattach them were
throwing people into vats of salt water
cold salt water and measuring how long
it took them to freeze to death so there
was something above and beyond what was
going on anywhere else in the world but
it was a matter of degree and not kind
because most other medical researchers
weren't obtaining consent from subjects
either at that point in time
Nuremberg impact is interesting to
reflect on because it's impossible to
hear a lecture about research ethics or
read a book about it without Nuremberg
playing a central role and yet its
practical impact was exceedingly limited
it got several of the Nazi doctors
executed and others into a prison made a
statement to the world but this standard
was largely an aspirational standard and
here in the United States as in other
Western countries it tended to be
discounted by physicians who were
conducting medical research on the
grounds that look those kinds of
practices what was going on there those
were that was research on prisoners in
death camps that has nothing to do with
us we're not Nazis we're trying to help
people and so this whole business of you
know getting consent and voluntary
consent being essential I mean that
that's true but it's true in in prisons
and death camps not in our hospitals
where we're just doing this stuff to try
to help people and it's clear that
studies without patients knowledge or
consent in medical settings continued
into the 1960s because of the
deficiencies of Nuremberg the world
medical association in 1964 convenes in
Helsinki and develops a document called
the Declaration of Helsinki which exists
to this day but has been repeatedly
updated and revised but you can go
online to the world Medical Association
website and read the declaration in its
original form it had an interesting
reaction to Nuremberg it said consent
was absolutely required for
non-therapeutic clinical research so if
I want to you know observe whether you
can get gangrene if I make a cut in your
leg and rub dirt into it then I need
your consent but if I'm conducting
clinical
cool research combined with patient care
and I as a physician determine that
consent is not in your best interest by
whatever standard I would make that
judgment then I don't have to obtain
your consent now in the 1960s a number
of things come together that lead to a
change and a change that's with us to
this day there were in the United States
a number of very high-profile scandals
newspaper expose A's of do you remember
newspapers by the way anybody expose of
studies in which people were exposed to
harm without their knowledge or consent
for example you know in the city of New
York in a hospital that doesn't exist
anymore was called the Jewish chronic
disease hospital in Brooklyn elderly
somewhat demented patients were injected
with cancer cells in an effort to learn
something about how the body rejected
cancer cells recognize them as foreign
when that hits the news you can
understand how people reacted adversely
to that moreover in 1966 henry beecher
the descendant of the famed feature
family publishes an article in the new
england journal of medicine every
Beecher is the chair of anesthesiology
at Mass General in Boston at that point
and one of the leading by definition one
of the leading anesthesiologists in the
country and he publishes an article in
The New Englander in all the country's
leading medical journal in which he
gives short paragraph long descriptions
of 22 published articles which he thinks
constitute unethical research and many
of them are examples of research being
conducted
without patients consent or research
that's highly likely to be harmful to
patients most of this is is clinical
research interestingly beatriz article
causes a big stir it's a real classic
you should read it if you have it yeah
but if you go back to the original
article what you'll see is that there
are no references there's no citation to
these published studies now with very
little work even in the pre-google era
you could have figured out who studies
these were and one of them was the
Willowbrook study on Staten Island in
which people with mental retardation who
were hospitalized at Willowbrook were
exposed deliberately inoculated with
hepatitis virus in an effort a
successful effort to develop a hepatitis
vaccine but the editors of the New
England Journal thought that it would be
ungentlemanly for one physician to
directly criticize other physicians for
unethical behavior by making their
identities public all of this culminates
in 1972 with the disclosures of the
Tuskegee study you all know about
Tuskegee cohort of black men in Alabama
in 1932 who are recruited identified as
having syphilis recruited to a study and
then followed to see what would happen
what the natural history of syphilis
would be there was no great treatment
for syphilis in 1932 although arsenicals
the Magic Bullet Ehrlich's Magic Bullet
existed already they were about they had
a 50-50 chance of killing you or curing
you so not everybody was willing to take
the treatment but of course by World War
two we had penicillin and after World
War Two penicillin was widely available
and nobody told these men that they had
syphilis and nobody told them that it
could be treated and in fact active
efforts were made in the early 1940s to
keep them out of the army because they
would have a Wasserman test they would
be diagnosed as having syphilis and they
would be treated and that would ruin the
study so pretty horrible thing it
whistle blower finally brings it to
public attention in the early 1970s and
finally with with this build-up Congress
in 1974 in acts the National Research
Act which sets up a commission to make
recommendations about regulating human
subjects research now to Joel's question
at the same time beginning in the
mid-1950s the notion that patients
should be asked for their consent to
treatment not to research begins to
arise in American courts not in the
american medical profession
interestingly but in American courts the
first case is in 1955 Stanford of salgo
versus Leland Stanford Hospital out in
California and the sort of landmark case
in 1959 is Natan sin versus Klein from
the Supreme Court of Kansas and by the
early 1970s there's a triad of cases in
1971 that really shaped informed consent
law to this day disclosure in clinical
settings is required there's some
discussion about what standard
disclosure has to live up to but it is
possible to sue doctors who don't
disclose the risks and benefits of the
treatments that they're recommending or
the alternatives and consent forms begin
to be developed in clinical context as
well so put it all together and that
leads up to the promulgation in 1981 of
federal regulations that have their
precursors in some earlier regs from
70's that are developed by the
department of health and human services
that require for the first time for all
federally funded research the consent of
human subjects which can be waived but
only in limited circumstances allow for
the possibility of surrogate consent
mandate written consent as the general
rule with the possibility of opting out
and require and this is you know the
biggest innovation of all in many ways
prospective review of research protocols
before implementation by what was called
an institutional review board or IRB and
other countries when they adopt this
model which most of the world most of
the developed world has now refer to
these committees as re CS or research
ethics committees or something similar I
RBS are required these are excerpts from
the federal regs but you can sort of
focus on the red highlights the
following conditions be met in order for
protocols to be approved that risks to
subjects are minimized that they're
reasonable in relation to the
anticipated benefits if any that
subjects are selected equitably that
informed consent will be sought and
appropriately documented that if
necessary a plan for monitoring the
safety of subjects should be created and
implemented and that there are adequate
protections of the privacy of subjects
as well those are the core requirements
for IRB approval to this day if you're
interested in looking at this in
somewhat more detail Google common rule
because the federal regulations go by
the name of the common rule and it will
come right up on your at the top of your
google search if you're going to obtain
informed consent which most researchers
have
to do the federal regulations require an
explanation of the purposes of the
research the procedures that will be
followed risks or discomforts benefits
appropriate alternatives including the
alternative of treatment outside of
research a statement about the
confidentiality of the research records
whether any compensation will be
provided and who could be contacted if
subjects have questions and then a clear
statement that participation is
voluntary there's some optional
provisions which can be included which i
haven't mentioned here depending on the
nature of the study but that's the
framework whoops that we essentially
have today and that's how we got there
through a series of scandals and this
steps by medical researchers that
persuaded the public that without
prospective review and tight regulation
the public would not be safe in the
hands of medical researchers and given
the history of the field the sad history
it's a little hard to argue that that
was not correct let me pause for a
second here this is the historical part
of the talk i'm going to move now to
talk a little bit about where we may be
going some hot issues and and the
direction in which the field may be
evolving but let's see if you've got
questions or comments
by the
yeah the transcripts of the trials which
are published are actually sort of
interesting to to read they made a
number of arguments in their defense one
what one was we're only following orders
a second was these people were going to
die anyway it wasn't because of us that
they were going to die they were in the
death camps they were going to die and
so to benefit humankind we decided to do
these experiments because they were
going to die anyway and why waste their
lives when their deaths could actually
contribute to the advancement of human
knowledge and there were appeals to the
importance of the work that had been
done which pretty uniformly today is
generally agreed to have been worthless
there's some arguments about rare
exceptions but by and large the studies
were were worthless but but those were
the those were the essence of the
defense claims yeah these into the
teaching ideas
is to CD started welcome ski he starts
in 1932 but nobody knows about it it's a
it's a well kept secret until late
nineteen seventy one and then it really
doesn't break until 72 so they had no
idea of that but they did argue in their
defense that they were being held to a
standard that nobody else was being held
to that in the United States in England
and you know France before the war
nobody got consent from patients prior
to doing research and you know as I say
there was some validity to the argument
but it's also true that much of what
they did looked more like torture than
it looked like genuine medical research
if you're interested Miriam I can
suggest some books that are really good
explorations of a whole the whole set of
issues that were involved in the trials
there was a foetus or another hand no ok
so let's push on and what I thought I
would do would be to just highlight and
there are many other issues we could
talk about and you may want to raise
them three issues that I think are now
in play in the world of research ethics
the questions related to the
effectiveness of consent and the
prevalence of therapeutic misconception
whether prospective review of research
which has been in place for 40 years now
is going to continue indefinitely into
the future or whether alternative
mechanisms may be developed at least for
some research and then the role of
consent and comparative effectiveness
research so Bob referred earlier to this
concept of a therapeutic misconception
and I just want to define it for you
here a therapeutic misconception is a
phenomenon that we see in research
subjects who
fail after disclosure and a consent
process to grasp the difference between
what goes on in clinical research and
what goes on in ordinary treatment and
they tend to in accurately attribute the
aspects the characteristics of ordinary
treatment to the research setting
particularly therapeutic intent that is
to say they think that entering a
research study is for the purpose of
getting the best possible treatment as
opposed to advancing knowledge so I'll
show you some data from a study we did
almost 15 years ago now which is the
largest one that's been done to date
looking at therapeutic misconception and
we defined it along two dimensions and
incorrect belief that your treatment
would be individualized to what you need
it and an unreasonable belief about the
nature or likelihood that you would
benefit from being in the study and what
we found was that almost two-thirds of
research subjects manifested a serious
misconception as to one or both of these
after going through the consent process
this difficulty with informed consent
and the general problems that research
subjects have in understanding what's
communicated to them has led to a
variety of efforts to improve
understanding of videotape disclosures
multimedia kinds of interactive computer
programs to get consent user-friendly
consent forms there are consent forms
being used today in medical research
studies multi-site medical research
studies that are more than 30 pages
single-spaced pages in length that are
written in almost effectively
impenetrable combinations of medical and
legal jargon that nobody reads and we
all know that nobody reads them because
nobody's going to sit down and read 30
single-spaced pages they won't even read
20 or 10 single-spaced pages and yet we
continue to produce these forms and to
obtain patients consent on these forms
which actually more accurately means
obtaining research subjects signatures
on the forms so some people have tried
making them a little more user-friendly
streamlining them etc people have tried
interacting repetitively with subjects
testing them afterwards and then giving
them feedback to try to correct the
incorrect perceptions that they have or
some combinations of these approaches
Florian Emanuel who did a review of the
literature a decade ago suggested that
the most promising interventions were
those that involved human interaction
with research subjects so more so than
video or computer aided disclosure which
had variable results sitting somebody
down in front of a another human being
and giving them a chance to ask
questions and to hear responses and have
that person
them what they need to know was the most
effective but when you think about it
also the least likely to be implemented
on a wide scale widespread scale because
it's the most expensive intervention and
it requires scarce time of expensive
personnel so where is this likely to go
now we are seeing movement towards not
so much more interaction with human
beings but towards more of these
interventions of what I've called
variable impact down here lots of I
arbys now are there not simplifying
their consent forms which they should be
but at the very least they're requiring
investigators have one-page summaries
that begin the consent forms as a way of
giving research subjects some prayer of
actually understanding what's going on
here that's a step in the right
direction it just doesn't go in my view
quite far enough but it's not a bad
thing in its own right there's a lot of
effort being put in now to a video
computer-aided disclosure some
colleagues and I wrote a paper year or
two ago arguing that computers give us
the opportunity now to individualize
disclosure for research subjects that is
you could produce a readable consent
screen or series of screens with
hyperlinks and let people click on
anything they wanted to know more about
and go back and reread anything they
were confused about and at the end ask
questions about anything that they still
didn't have down in a way that would
really produce something much closer to
individualize disclosure and there are
again there are X
our mental models of this but it's not
being done anywhere on a widespread
basis there even some proprietary
companies that are trying to do this and
sell it but it has not yet caught on
along with a colleague I've worked with
for a long time Chuck lids who was my
colleague we were colleagues on the
original therapeutic misconception study
in the early 1980s Chuck is the PI on a
grant that we have from NIH which should
be starting soon to look at another
approach which is an attempt to reframe
the way research participants think
about what they're getting into that is
it's our belief that many of patients
enter a clinical research become
research subjects but retain a
therapeutic mindset a clinical approach
to the whole setting and we've always
thought that if we tell them explicitly
just explain to them the nature of an
experimental approach to testing
hypotheses and the reasons that things
in research are done differently than
treatment like your doctor won't know
what medication you're getting and
neither will you why do we do that we're
not going to pick which treatment you
get there's a computer that's going to
spew out a number at random that's going
to tell us what your treatment is why do
we do that some people are going to get
an active treatment and others are going
to get a placebo an inactive compound
why do we do that to attempt to explain
that concisely the subjects we think
stands a shot at breaking through some
of the barriers to understanding of what
it means to be in a research study and
we now have an r21 grant to try to
figure that out
that says three but it should say two if
you've been counting this is the second
issue that I want to just talk about
with you briefly and this is the
question of what the future of our IRB
model is likely to be today I arbys
engage in a an expensive and
time-consuming process of review of
research protocols without a lot of
evidence suggesting great benefit from
the process so almost all research in
the u.s. today is subject of prospective
review by arbys IRB staff are now
professionalized they become certified
IRP IRB professionals large medical
centers have multiple I arbys at the
Medical Center we have three general I
arbys and two specialty I RBS and
there's another IRB for this campus as
well so there are six I rbs all together
overseeing research at Columbia
accreditation standards have been
developed and it costs a lot of money so
in 2003 the cost of a high volume IRB
was estimated at over three quarters of
a million dollars today that number is
probably twice as much and that doesn't
count everybody's time involved in
negotiating the IRB process since that
time new compliance requirements have
been added new training requirements
have been added it's a much more
expensive process today the average
duration of review is about three months
which is a little horrifying and
multi-site studies typically require
review at each of the sites could have
more than 40 sites in your study you
could have more than 70 sites in your
study in general each one of them has to
review the
research there's a lot of delay a lot of
cost a lot of concern about in
particularly in the social sciences
about censorship of research studies
limiting the questions that can be asked
and we know from a number of studies
including studies we've done that the
majority of IRB effort is spent
reviewing consent forms the least useful
aspect of the process soaks up the most
effort one study found ninety-one
percent of requests for changes to
protocols were for changes to the
wording of the consent forms which
nobody reads is a little secret and
investigators as a result have also
learned that they ought to put a lot of
effort into writing their forms and
maybe less effort into making sure their
subjects understand what the studies are
about because nobody goes back to look
at whether or not the subjects
understand all they look at are the
forms the forms have gotten longer and
longer i'm not going to read you the
numbers but take that as a
generalization and the question is what
can we do about it well there are some
things that are being tested and
implemented now that I'm not going to
talk about in detail including the use
of central IRB s one IRB that can review
a protocol for a multi-site study to
eliminate the need for 40 irvs to do the
same thing iteratively but two years ago
now HHS issued in the Federal Register
is something called an advanced notice
of proposed rulemaking in which they put
out for public comment a number of
changes to the way research regulation
takes place because they know nobody's
happy with it and they're not
particularly happy with it either and
one of the things they proposed which
bought listenin and I wrote about
in a piece and science last year little
commentary in science is a model of
regulation of minimal risk studies that
gets away from prospective review they
propose that for many minimal risk
studies investigators could just
register the study and go right to it
and that the I arbys would selectively
pull out certain studies to review more
closely in a retrospective fashion
without needing to review them all
because most people think there's not
much gain from all the effort that goes
into review of minimal risk research the
clear advantages would be greater
efficiency you're only reviewing a small
portion of the studies you'd be
reviewing what actually happens not
what's proposed that is you could go
back and ask how well the protocols were
implemented did subjects actually
understand what they were told as
opposed to would they be likely to
understand and you can build in to a
retrospective review process a mechanism
for appellate review which doesn't exist
now right now I arbys are the court of
last resort they say no your only
alternative is to go right back to that
same IRB and ask again maybe more nicely
this time so there's a great deal of
sentiment building for rethinking I
arbys a couple of hands yeah disappear
yeah so the question is is focused on
what's happened in the last two years
with that advanced notice of proposed
rulemaking which is nothing there was a
public comment period and we've heard
nothing from HHS since that point in
time why I don't know for sure and HHS
isn't talking about this
my guess is that this is a sensitive
area whatever you do hear somebody is
going to object to it and the pressure
to move forward may have lessened with
some personnel changes in the federal
government seek Emanuel who was sort of
driving this process left the government
and is it pent now and there's just
nobody who's willing to spend the
political capital it would take to make
these changes I was on a committee for
Zach harp which is the Secretary's
Advisory Committee for Human Research
protections in which we came up with
proposals for changing the way research
is done with people with impaired
decision-making capacity and we made you
know a report this is probably four
years ago now which is sat on a shelf
ever since but the the staff from ohrp
the office of Human Research protections
was very clear that they thought
changing the common rule was nearly
impossible it was a process that we take
ten years at a minimum to get all the
agencies sign off and you know review by
the office of the budget and etc and
they were essentially in helpless
hopeless mode about any changes so I
mean there you go it just hasn't moved
there was another hand yeah
and
they do now that's the day
reported adverse event
Paula and I
I
the following indices and
right so procedures are similar here in
the United States in both respects there
is an option for expedited review in the
regs but our IRB for example likes to
say just because review is expedited
doesn't mean it's going to be faster it
means that it doesn't have to go to the
full RB there's one person who's
designated to review it or sometimes a
small group but it tends to take a very
long period of time and it's limited to
specific categories defined in the regs
which doesn't include all minimal of
risk research but only these defined
categories of research similarly adverse
events have to be reported because
safety is a concern but for example the
effectiveness of your consent process
doesn't have to be monitored or reported
in general unless the RB requires that
specifically which it usually does not
but did you have another piece to that
you all the best just something and
articulate this
randomized
and now the service state is changing
the doctors that
and first place
trials
so one of the hot areas is and so called
n of 1 trials where you're focused on
the needs of an individual patient it's
often linked to genomic sequencing and
targeted medication interventions etc so
let me let me push on ahead and just
quickly talk about the the real third
point here and that's the role of
consenting comparative effectiveness
research there's a group at Johns
Hopkins Ruth Faden Nancy cass and others
Tom Beecham who interestingly have
proposed thinking about consent
differently in what they call based on a
report from the Institute of Medicine a
couple years ago a learning health
system the notion is that our healthcare
systems should always be learning from
the experience of treating patients that
means routinely collecting and analyzing
data it also means routinely comparing
different ways of doing things to know
which one works better and that's so
essential a function of a learning
health system that we should not need to
ask patients for their consent because
in their view in such kinds of research
there's not a distinction between
research and treatment even if people
are randomized to you know two ways of
you had surgery you're going to be in
bed for two days and you're going to be
in bed for four days but we're not going
to give you a choice that we're not
going to tell you that you were
randomized because we just need to know
whether two days or four days is a
better way of doing it so unless there's
a negative effect on expected clinical
outcomes or other outcomes or values
that matter morally to patients we don't
have to bother getting their consent
that quote is from an article published
last week in the New England Journal of
Medicine
which had a response from to folks who I
know at NIH who aren't quite so ready to
walk away from the consent of model but
learning health systems are a big buzz
word these days and part of the reaction
to the difficulty of moving things
through I arbys and getting consent from
lots of subjects has been to say let's
Rican sexualize the whole thing and just
carve out a big area where we're not
even going to follow the usual rules of
consent we're just going to include
people we're going to get their data and
we're going to do it because everybody
will benefit from it so it's a greater
good argument it's a real utilitarian
argument but it ignores really 40 years
of thought now about the importance of
individual consent and individual
autonomy and deciding whether or not you
want to be part of a research study and
there are all kinds of questions which
I'm not going to go into now and that
that brings us to your remaining
questions and comments so just on that
last proposal it seeks to that a country
that had a age created national health
could be doing that and do we know of
any it is any nation actually trying to
use their public health service data to
create
learning system so I think the answer is
yes and the Scandinavian countries are a
model of that everybody has a as I say
sperm to worm health record that
contains all of their medical
information we only aspire to such
things in the United States and there
are excellent population registries of
other sorts of things as well from
accidental deaths with suicide deaths to
substance use cetera and some of the
best public health research in the world
comes out of Scandinavia because they've
devoted decades to building these kinds
of record systems even the National
Health Service in England in Great
Britain is ahead of us in terms of of
these kinds of efforts
always useful where's Ben courts views
on how useful
is there a big difference between what
happens in clinical practice versus what
happens
the mistake
so the most interesting thing to my mind
in the litigation over harms that relate
to participation in research is how
little there is of it in 1987 some
colleagues and I wrote a book on
informed consent part of which address
consent to research and at that point we
went through the case law to find what
the presidents were and there were no
precedent well we're a few years later
now you know 27 years later and there
are precedents but there aren't very
many and you could easily summarize them
in one of paper there hasn't been a lot
of litigation so why hasn't there been a
lot of litigation you know you could say
in part the system may have worked there
aren't a lot of injuries that occur as a
result of negligence in medical research
it may also be that the system sort of
impenetrable and until recently we
didn't have attorneys who specialized in
bringing such cases I now know of two in
the country whose practice is sort of
basically limited to suing researchers
and you know I've been involved in a
number of such suits over the years both
for plaintiffs and defendants but to get
more directly to your question do the
courts take consent seriously and how
they deal with the consent forms in
these cases I would say they deal with
the consent forms the same way they do
with consent to clinical treatment that
is there tends to be an assumption that
if it was on the form the person read it
and understood it if their signature is
at the bottom of the form so there's a
protective effect in law even if in
reality we all know that the person
really hasn't understood what they've
read and that contributes to just
doing more of the same making them
longer and putting more information in
them because someday you may want a
defense lawyer waving it in front of a
jury on your behalf and saying mrs.
smith signed this form how can she tell
you now that she never knew that we were
going to be you know taking out half a
lobe of her brain it says so right in
the form look it's on page 16 in the
fourth paragraph so that that tends to
be how it plays out okay well please
join me in thanking